sie zählen zu den größten katastrophen
die im weltall passieren können so
genannte tdi steidl des roxy events auf
deutsch gezeiten bedingtes
auseinanderreißen das passiert nämlich
nicht selten wenn ein stern in ein super
massereiches schwarzes loch im zentrum
einer galaxie sturz dann würde nämlich
durch die riesige schwerkraft des
schwarzen loches zerrissen die berühmte
spaghetti sierung wenn etwas in ein
schwarzes loch fällt das dramatische
folgen die auf der erde beobachtet
werden können jetzt ein klick vom
science fiction herzlich willkommen
hier in unserem sonnensystem haben wir
über alles mögliche unendlich viel daten
wie groß sind die planeten wie bewegen
sich was passiert auf der sonne und und
wir werden sehr viel über das was um uns
herum passiert doch umso weiter planeten
sterne und galaxien entfernt sind desto
schwieriger wird es etwas über sie zu
erfahren
deshalb tüfteln astronom und astronomen
immer weiter wie man anhand welcher
daten was über die entfernten
himmelskörper erfahren kann
besonders spannend sind dabei die
schwarzen löcher von denen wir ja noch
immer keinen bilder wir haben keine
ahnung wie sie aussehen nur theoretische
erkenntnisse die uns vermuten lassen wie
wahrscheinlich aussehen würden wenn wir
in ihrer nähe wären gerade wird er
versucht ein bild des schwarzen loches
in der mitte unserer galaxie der
milchstraße von sagittarius stern mit
hilfe von daten ganz verschiedener
teleskope zu machen
doch noch wird dann angerechnet bisher
haben wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin
die größe von solchen schwarzen löchern
aufgrund der strahlenden
akkretionsscheibe numm wer ermittelt
oder haben die umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit
'nen der sterne um diese
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher
ermittelt doch mal fährt 88 ersann der
astronom martin rief eine andere methode
wie viel exakter wäre wenn es möglich
wäre zu beobachten wie ein einzelner
stern in ein solches riesiges loch
stürzt dann könnten mit diesem
beobachtung viel exaktere erkenntnisse
über die galaxien fan geworden werden
dass sterne bei einem solchen ereignis
spaghetti wir werden das wird schon seit
neuestem sie vermutet doch pause noch
bis um die jahrtausendwende bis solche
ereignisse zum ersten mal entdeckt
wurden die riesigen datenmengen die
teleskope heutzutage sammeln und jeder
anfang computern durchforstet werden
machen solche entdeckung inzwischen viel
leichter möglichst viele cds also teile
des wracks events das gezeigte bedingte
auseinanderreißen die sind extrem
seltsam ihre akkretionsscheibe will zu
kalt sie enthalten trotzdem juni wird
das helium es fehlt wasserstoff die
erzeugen gammastrahlen und und und und
sie werden zu selten gefunden um all
diese räte zu kehren und das soll sich
jetzt ändern in chile wird das land von
optik server teleskop
sst gebaut es deckt mit zehn quadrat
finkel graf ein besonders großes feldes
ab im ersten jahrzehnt seines betriebs
soll es von tausende teenies entdecken
das bedeutet einen riesigen fortschritt
für die forschung rund um
supermassereiche schwarze löcher und wir
werden viel viel mehr über sie erfahren
wenn du soweit ist werden wir natürlich
hier darüber berichten
wenn er kein video verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergeblich den auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit das rätsel der
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher wenn
euch dieses video an dieses hier
interessiert dann ist das auch perfekt
für euch also darauf gelegt worden wenn
ich dann würde ich mal sagen bis dann
leichter